Let's move on to the next one because
this one is
um
Oh, by the way,
what was that? names, you know, that in
chapter 3, verse 54 and 8:30,
the greatest of all deceivers.
>> of all deceivers, Allah is the greatest
of all deceivers. The greatest of the
deceivers. Yeah.
>> That's right. That's
>> of the deceivers. That's
chapter 3, verse 54 of the Quran.
Um the next one
which probably you have addressed it a
million times and
other apologists have answered that. I
think I have answered it about 50,000
times is
Jesus never says or never claims
anywhere in the Bible you will never
find that Jesus says, "I am God, worship
me."
I mean that's probably one of the
classic ones, isn't it, brother? Yeah,
this is Yeah, this is the one I heard
when I first came into the faith and
because I was young and
not very well trained in the faith, you
know, that stumped me, but this is what
we call the exact word fallacy. Now,
if they want to play that game, number
one, it's an argument from silence. At
best, all they're showing is we don't
have anything in the New Testament that
says he said it. But just because it's
not recorded doesn't mean he didn't say
it. This is what we call arguing from
silence.
Arguments from silence, unless you have
sufficient grounds
to use that form of argumentation is
bad.
Just because it doesn't record that he
said it, how do you know he didn't say
it? Because the Bible itself says it
doesn't write down everything Jesus said
or did.
Mhm. Right that's in John chapter 20,
verse 30 and John 21:25. It says, "Not
everything Jesus did, not everything
Jesus said has been recorded."
So, that's an argument science. So,
number two,
if you're going to use that argument,
then you're going to have to be
consistent and honest and apply the same
standard to yourself. For example,
unless
Jesus says something, you won't believe
it. Well, therefore,
why do you believe Jesus
is the Messiah, the word of Allah sent
down to Mary in the spirit from him? Why
do I say that? Nowhere in the Quran will
you find Jesus saying in your Quran, and
I don't believe Jesus speaking, but you
you believe it. What does he say I am
the Messiah?
What does he say I'm the son of Mary?
What does he say I'm born of a virgin?
What does he say I'm the word of Allah
sent down from Allah to Mary and I'm a
spirit from him? Because two of the
honorific titles that Islam gives to
Jesus is kalimat Allah, word of Allah,
ruh Allah, spirit of Allah, taken from
4:171, but nowhere does Jesus say that
about himself. So, if I follow your
reasoning, I can't follow the Quran
because you don't have Jesus saying I am
the Messiah, al masih, I am the virgin
born son of Mary,
I'm born of the Virgin Mary, I am the
word of Allah sent down to Mary in the
spirit from him. So, that means you got
to reject the Quran. See how stupid that
is? Exactly. You arrived to that
conclusion because you read a text. It
doesn't mean that it need it needs to be
exactly word by word. It says it in
order to mean it. Yep. You just arrive
you read it, you arrive to that
conclusion. And then um
um what verse or what part of
uh the Quran would you use? Of course,
he was born of a virgin, kalimatullah,
ruh Allah, he he he he he raised the
dead.
He is the alpha and the omega, the
beginning and the end.
What would you use that you say maybe he
didn't say it in the exact word, but we
come to the conclusion that he is God
and he accepted worship? Yep. Yep. In
fact, just to add one more thing to
that. And if they're going to be
consistent, I want them to show me where
Muhammad says in the Quran I am the
prophet of Allah. Muhammad's saying
that, I am the prophet of Allah. I am
the seal
of the prophets. Not the Quran saying
that about Muhammad. I know Muhammad
says I'm a messenger,
right? I'm a messenger and all that's
all I am is a messenger.
But what can you show me where Muhammad
says, "I am the prophet of Allah, I'm
the seal of the prophets." Not the Quran
saying it about him, Muhammad saying it
of himself. If he didn't then I'm going
to reject the Quran. You see how silly
that is? Now coming back to It is really
silly. It is very stupid.
There are various ways you can show
that
if the Muslims believe what the Quran
says, then they're going to have to
admit that Jesus claimed to be God in
the Bible, even though they're going to
reject the Bible.
So I'm not
using this to prove except the Bible.
I'm saying
Now be honest with me.
Do you admit that at least
the Bible has Jesus claiming to be God
without having to use those exact words.
So how would I go about it? Well, here
again, if you bring this up and enlarge
this. Here you go. All right. How would
I go about it? These are some passages
that we've used in actual evangelism,
they work.
My most
famous one is this, 57:3.
He is the first and the last, the
outward and the inward, and he's the
knower of all things.
So you ask them, "Who's the first and
last?"
Al Awwal wal Aakhir.
That's Allah. Can a creature say he's
the first and last? No. And the Quran
doesn't say that of a creature.
All right, he's the first and last. So
then, and by the way, the Old Testament
agrees.
So if I'm dealing with a Jehovah
Witness, I'll also do show them this.
All right. All right, Jehovah Witness.
Who's the first and the last? They
agree.
Quran agrees.
Old Testament agrees. That's a title
that only God
can apply to himself. Isaiah 44:6, "Thus
says Yahweh, the king of Israel and his
redeemer, Yahweh of hosts, I'm the first
and I'm the last. There's no god besides
me."
So far the Quran is aping the Old
Testament. I don't believe Allah of the
Quran is God of the Bible, but
nonetheless, for argument's sake.
Isaiah 48:12, "Hear me, O Jacob, even
Israel whom I called, I am he, I'm the
first and I'm also the last." Good.
Revelation 1:17.
When I saw him, I fell at his feet like
a dead man. He placed his right hand on
me saying, "Do not fear, I am the first
and the last."
>> Amen. There's no denying this is God.
Old Testament says
this is the name for God. Quran says his
name for Allah, but this one says, "I'm
the first last, the living one, and I
was dead."
Yep. So then I asked the Muslim, "When
did your God Allah die?" He goes, "He
didn't die." Yeah, he did. Cuz this is
Allah speaking, right? First and last.
But that's Jesus. Also, you just admit
Jesus claimed to be God. And behold, I'm
alive forever and ever, and I have the
keys of death and of Hades.
So that's one.
For the second time, I'll give another
one that's just as hard-hitting.
But I want as you as you're looking up
that I love this argument and it works
every single time. It truly it just when
you bring that these two verses right
next to one another, it just settles it.
And then the best part of it is you show
them the verse 17 in Revelation first
Yep. and then they're going to confirm
and then read a little more and then
just hit the nail on the head.
Precisely. So right there, but now
here's the one that's just as strong.
Just as strong. I won't say stronger.
You go to chapter 22:6-7. We're just
giving you just some
highlights.
This is why we invite you. Go back to my
YouTube channel, watch the sessions I've
done, go to his channel, go to the blog,
read the articles, take the material,
it's yours, study them, master them,
share them.
Okay. This to me is just as powerful.
Why?
I'm going to read Arberry cuz he'll
translate the word Allah as God. This is
because God, he is the truth, al-haqq.
The truth. Yep. With that in mind,
brings the dead to life
and is powerful over everything.
And because the hour is coming, no doubt
of it, and God shows up whomsoever is
within the tomb. So you ask them,
"You agree the Quran only calls Allah
the truth? It's never used for anyone
else? Yes. Yes. You also agree the
Quoran says the hour, meaning the last
day, Yamma Qiyamma?
It is God, Allah, who will then give
life to the dead by raising them from
the tombs? Yes. Notice it even says
hour. This again shows you Muhammad is
an heir. Because you know where he got
this from?
He stole it from Jesus. Exactly. What do
I mean?
Now, I'm going to line it up so you can
see what I mean.
He stole it from Jesus.
All right?
For sure, yeah. And uh he didn't come up
with those things
uh from a vacuum. He had the Christians
and Jews, and of course the Bible was uh
written at his time, and he had access
to all of it. So, he heard all of these
things.
>> So, again, to remind you what I'm trying
to show you,
the Quoran says Allah is the truth. Say
Tell them, "Show me in the Quoran
someone other than Allah called the
truth." They can't.
Brings the dead to life, and then it
says at the hour, meaning last day, God,
Allah, will raise them from tombs tombs,
meaning physically. Now, let's do what
Jesus says. Compare.
John 5:21. Note he's not the father, but
he's equal to the father. For just as
the father raised to the dead and gives
them life, even so the son also gives
life to whom he wishes. So,
>> Hallelujah. he's not the father, but
equal to the father, and he became
flesh, and he can do what the father
does, raise the dead and gives them
life. By the way, it gets worse for the
Muslims.
Here's that language, hour.
Remember what the Quoran said in 22:7?
>> Yep. The hour is coming, have no doubt
about it, where God will raise them from
the tombs. Jesus speaking.
Truly, truly I say to you, John 5:25.
An hour is coming,
and now is when the dead will hear the
voice of the son of God, Yep. and those
who hear will live.
Whose voice? The son of God, right?
>> God,
29, same chapter. Do not marvel at this
for an hour is coming in which all were
in the tombs.
When? The hour in the tombs will hear
his voice. In case you missed it, so
they don't play games with you.
Hear the voice of the son of God. Those
in the tombs at the hour will hear the
voice of the son of God
and will come forth. Those who did the
good deeds or resurrection of life.
Those who committed evil deeds for
resurrection of judgment. Remember it
says Allah is the truth and he gives
life to the dead? Look what Jesus says.
John 11:25-26.
Jesus says,
"I am the resurrection and the life."
And these are some of the names of
Allah, al-bayyit, the raiser of the
dead, 22:6.
And the light, meaning the one who gives
life, right? Al-hayy, right?
Who believes in me
will live even if he dies and everyone
who lives and believes in me will never
die ever. Do you believe this?
John 14:6. Jesus said to him, "I am the
way and the truth and the life."
No one comes to the Father but through
me. Wait, he's the truth, he's the life,
he's al-bayyit, the raiser of the dead.
He gives life to the dead and the hour
is coming where they will hear the voice
of the son of God and they'll come out
of the tombs. That's what the Quran says
of Allah.
That is because God, he is the truth,
al-haqq, and brings the dead of to life
and is powerful over all
over everything. And because the hour is
coming, no doubt of it, and God shall
raise up whosoever within the tombs.
Well, you see, Jesus himself is the one
who used the phrase hour.
The hour is coming. Jesus used that over
600 years before Muhammad was born.
And he says, "I am the God, not the
Father, cuz I'm a son,
who at the hour will raise them
spiritually and physically by the power
of the sound of my glorious voice."
You see what I'm saying?
>> [snorts]
>> This is uh folks, this is like the
perfect class, perfect apologetic class
that with every reference that you need
to the objections that we're presenting
to you, supposedly Muslims, they think
they're going to catch Christians with
this and and uh trap them with this.
Here the references,
here the clear response. You just learn
this, master this, use this very um
uh topic, use this very uh um
resources, and just calmly answer those,
and then that's how you go about it.
Yep.
Well, that's it. That's awesome. Praise
God.